und ich glaube das muss man wissen wenn
man videos von abwehrmann video von
upgrades star toni mit dislike da lässt
und irgendwann würden kommentar schreibt
dann führt das nicht dazu dass der typ
seine kanal strategie überdenkt oder
irgendwas anders machen sondern dann
macht er genau das was apa/red von euch
möchte das werk ist und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video in ihr
heute mal beim thema reden was viele von
euch sicher sehr interessiert was viele
vielleicht noch nicht ganz verstanden
haben und von den titel gesehen es geht
heute darum warum upgrade den hate
braucht wie bin ich auf die idee für das
video gekommen ganz einfach wenn ich zum
beispiel so ein video über ab und machen
dann schreiben wir viele du arschloch du
bist a bzw a parade hoch us-soldat und
ich glaube dass diese leute die
strategie von upgrade auf youtube nicht
ganz verstanden haben deswegen möchte
ich dir heute ein bisschen erklären so
wie ich die ganze geschichte wäre mir
nicht zu hause bin sicher wenn ihr eine
anomale könnte es gerne in die
kommentare schreiben hatte abbrennt
früher auch im ganz normalen kanal mit
videos gemacht der die sind das gemacht
aber ich glaube so wirklich bekannt
bekannt ist er erst geworden als er
angefangen hat mehr kontroverse inhalte
zu machen was heißt kontroverse inhalte
die viele leute sehr stark abstoßen die
piloten der blöd finden also zum
beispiel videos in der ganztagesbereich
in denen er wäre anstößige dinge macht
wie zum beispiel im bereich nach dem
terrorattentat wir können sich ungefähr
vorstellen was ich meine wenn ich sage
ja das upgrade in videos macht diesen
anschlüssen
denn für manche dazu gehört natürlich
auch wenn alle anderen möglichkeiten ich
persönlich glaube der ganzen sache dass
apa/red deutlich schlauer ist als die
meisten denken okay
die meisten würden vielleicht sagen ja
auch irgendwie so sehr der weiß es nicht
besser ich sage er weiß es besser weiß
ganz genau welche video sehr stark
diskutiert werden welche videos viele
schlecht finden was wiederum dazu führt
dass sollte sehr viel über ihn reden und
ich glaube das baut er ganz bewusst in
deine videos ein du mir sicher mehr als
einmal der videos gemacht wurde ich
nicht gedacht hat okay das bestmögliche
video ich kann das ich besser machen
dass es perfekt in meinen augen springt
so raus sondern eben dass er sich
gedacht hat okay weißt du was wenn ich
das mache wenn ich jetzt nach dem
terroranschlag in bombay trend mache
dann werde ich so viel öffentlichkeit
bekommen wir werden so viele leute
darüber reden und mich hassen und mit
mir aber ganz egal ob die leute mich
hatte ich will einfach nur reichweite
ich will einfach noch klick haben und
genau dafür ist diese strategie dass man
bewusst provoziert mit seinen videos
eben sehr sehr gut und ich mache dieses
video und zu erklären
das upgrade ist eben besser weiß was
meine meinung ist zu der ganzen sache da
könnt ihr gerne anderen meinung sein
aber ich glaube afrika ist nicht so blöd
wie die meisten darstellen wollen ich
glaube absolut ist eben
ich hängen geblieben sondern der spielt
ganz bewusst damit er weiß ganz genau
welche videos bei ihm kav negativ
ankommen und dadurch eine sehr sehr
große aufmerksamkeit bekommt ich glaube
er hat sich einfach irgendwann gedacht
dass jeweils gewachsen wir sind ok segal
ich möchte keine projekt konstant weil
wenn man folglich erfahren möchte dass
man mit unternehmen zusammenarbeiten
möchte die sagen okay weißt du was ich
gebe jetzt die kamera deckel ok den
zeigt in einem video redet bisschen
drüber dann kriegst für 10.000 euro so
dass interplay aber damit man voller
place machen kann muss die person also
der youtuber der die parkfläche macht
irgendwie auch für der marke passt zu
der marke zu dem unternehmen eben der
firma die dahinter steht die das geld an
die tür wird jetzt bei der sache aber so
dass er sehr vorsichtig die passen ganz
genau darauf welche youtuber ihre
produkte zeigen darf mit new jersey
zusammenarbeiten weil alles natürlich
ihr image als firma als marke
beschädigen kann was man mit youtube
macht wenn die youtuber schlecht beruf
haben dann überträgt sich auf die firma
weil youtube auch immer für die firma
steht die mit der firma zusammenarbeit
und deswegen glaube ich kriegt apa/red
keine polak technik
ich hab natürlich nicht jedes anbieters
aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass er
nicht so mega viele von uns haben kann
eben weil er so viel polarisiert und
auch immer wenn ich mit unternehmen rede
sagen diese operette mit dem machen wir
garantiert kein prophet und das läuft
und ich glaube er hat irgendwann gesagt
okay schalter voller kenntnis diesen
egal ich möchte einfach nur noch klick
machen ok meine neue strategie ist nicht
besonders sauberes image zu haben so das
unternehmen sagen ob jeweils wasser dem
format zusammen arbeiten im körper geld
geben das ist eine person die spur die
vernünftig der keinen schlechten
einfluss auf jugendliche mit der
coolness zusammenarbeiten
exakt irgendwann hat er so stelle ich
mir das vor gesagt okay ich weiß davon
abhängt ich möchte nur noch fix machen
und wie bekomme ich klicke wenn ich
klicks machen möchte ist mein image
eigentlich scheißegal wenn ich einfach
nur kicken möchte das heißt ich möchte
einfach nur dass leute meine videos
schauen wissen wer ich bin dann ist egal
wie ich diese aufmerksamkeit bekomme es
ist für die klickt und für die
werbeeinnahmen vollkommen egal wie so
leute auf dem video klicken also
komplett egal ob sie auf das video
klicken weil die personen die größte für
sie ist und sie niemand anderen mehr
sehen wollen ihrem leben oder ob ihr das
video klicken weil sie diese person so
sehr hat nun einfach nur im bösen
kommentare lassen wollen wenn leute auf
das video klicken und das video
anschauen kriegt der youtuber geld und
da ist es komplett egal aus welchem
grund die leute das video anklicken
deswegen glaube ich irgendwann ganz gut
eine provokation strategie gegangen hat
es gesagt okay es ist scheißegal wie die
aufmerksamkeit bekommen als hauptsache
ich bekomme aufmerksamkeit mir egal aus
welchem grund die leute meine videos
klicken
ich möchte einfach mal geklickt haben
und ich möchte die aufmerksamkeit haben
und deswegen glaube ich mach dir bewusst
solche aktion mit dem komplex der typ
ist hängen geblieben so der beiden
bomben nach dem terroranschlag einfach
in kraft doch bedeutet vielleicht
eröffnet ganz sicher dass es am ende
auch eine strafanzeige geht und alles
mögliche aber er weiß auf jeden fall
wusste das führt und wie gesagt meine
absicht dem video ist das zu erklären
warum er das gemacht weil ich glaube
viele leute nicht ganz verstehen wieso
er die videos macht ihr macht und jetzt
kann man auf dem video titel zurück also
ich glaube so langsam wird klar warum
ich denke dass abu raed in hey braucht
weist euch mal vor ihr habt eine gewisse
menge an leuten die eure videos gut
finden ok sie könnte erreichen die mir
einfach gute videos macht der ganz
normale videos die nicht so krass
polarisiert und dann habt ihr aber noch
mal eine andere menge an leuten die euch
einfach nur extrem hatten wir ja zum
beispiel videos macht wie ein bomben
fränk oder 24 stunden inne wenn man eben
nur auf klick geht sagt man sich okay
ich will dich notieren die mich gut
findet sondern spielt auch sie haben die
mich schlecht finden weil das sind
einfach deutlich mehr deutlich mehr
aufrufe deutlich mehr werbeeinnahmen mit
meinen videos und ich glaube das muss
man wissen wenn wir von abbyy wenn man
wie die von ihm in dislike glass und
irgendwie mögen kommentar schreibt dann
führt das nicht dazu dass der typ seine
kanal strategie überdenken oder
irgendwas anders macht sondern dann
macht er genau das upgrade von euch
möchte er möchte das jetzt eine videos
click mir ist es egal ob in ist ein
klassiker den typ überhaupt nicht so hat
sich darauf eingestellt dass er halt so
75% 50% discs auf videos hass und genau
für diese leute ist eben dieses video
die sich denken ob ich dir zu arbeiten
das im display und treffen damit damit
treffe den nicht leute das müsst ihr
unbedingt wissen
ihr helft ihnen damit denken wir mal
über solche dinge nach viva wagen oder
willst du mich kicken gab es nämlich
schickt oder jetzt ganz neu du kleiner
kleiner abgespeckter große du bist ein
kleiner großen sprüche und wörter da bin
ich mir ziemlich ziemlich sicher dass
ich von anfang an denkt okay da werden
sich viele viele viele leute darüber
lustig machen und in dem sich lustig
darüber machen positives unter alle
möglichen videos sagen hier barwagen
darüber wagen zuvor und auf einmal reden
alle wieder über updates man merkt es
auch immer seine videos schaut also
niemand verändert auf einmal seinen
sprachgebrauch so stark dass er von 0
auf
100 x 50 x du kleiner go in dem video
sagt ich glaube diese du kleiner ursache
ist eben auch einfach eine bewusste
strategie so man sagt einfach zehnmal
dann finden vielleicht die leute cool
die an mögen dann sagt man 20 30 40 50
mal stattfindet noch einmal die leute
scheiße die einen nicht mögen machen
sich darüber lustig postens überall um
eines wieder im gespräch und ich selbst
habe es am anfang nicht verstanden und
ich bin ja jetzt jemand der steckt ein
bisschen älter ist als manche von euch
diese videos schauen deswegen glaube ich
sehr wichtiger sich erkläre ihr favorit
nicht damit in die mehr auf seine videos
click und bleibt damit tut ihr ihm
eingefallen was heißt wenn ihr jetzt
denkt das absolut keine
daseinsberechtigung in die tube
deutschland hat was jetzt nicht meine
meinung wäre dann bringt das nicht
können dass deine videos click sondern
wenn man jetzt sagt okay ich möchte
abwarten nicht unterstützt und möchte
dass dieser content weniger
aufmerksamkeit bekommt dann dürft ihr
nicht auf dieses video klicken sondern
einfach gar nicht drauf klicken und auch
einfach gar nicht drüber gehen das ist
relativ schwer klar weil wenn irgendwas
aufregt möchte man darüber reden und
möchten eine meinung äußern aber gerade
in dem man seine meinung äußert hält
sich dieser kreislauf am laufen und es
geht immer weiter und alle reden immer
weiter ab und er macht wieder scheint
die leute reden wieder über ihn macht
wieder scheiße dort wieder bei ihnen
bringen kontroversen spruch leute reden
darüber machen sich darüber lustig aber
letzten endes ist ja immer im gespräch
alles klar also dass hat von diesem
kleinen topf video gewesen sein ich war
heute mega lange der uni 9 bis 18uhr
deswegen habe ich einfach noch keine für
ausgaben über ein thema was aber glaube
ich sehr sehr wichtig ist und was viele
noch bisschen besser durchdringen können
wenn ihr auf dem video etwas mitgenommen
abgewickelt und in die kommentare
schreiben mich hier abonnieren und johne
video abchecken bis zum nächsten mal
last light und bis heute